when I was just a kid on some holiday
staying at my grandma's house I remember
my first time properly seeing an ant
colony seeing hundreds of tiny creatures
going about their little tasks in such
an organized fashion created a flowing
pattern that mesmerised me for hours
like seriously I could just stare these
ants from morning till evening yeah I
know right the most popular kid in
school right here
but eventually wanting to learn where
these strange little creatures were
coming from I followed the trail of ants
to a small mound and as a kid there was
so much wonder and mystery behind that
mound what was in the mounds was
something controlling all these
creatures where are they all coming from
it was this curiosity that led me to try
to uncover the mysteries that lay in
that mounds using just a stick and of
course my bare hands I was a stupid
[ __ ] kid but decades later with a
painful memory I will never forget I
still find pleasure in itching that
childlike curiosity of exploration and
learning about the world beyond my
understanding it's something which I
think as some level we never really grow
out of and recently there have been two
anime that have been able to evoke this
childlike wonder of exploration and
discovery one being last season's made
an abyss and the other being the ancient
Magus bride which I'll be focusing on
today bird I will be sprinkling a bit of
maiden abyss here and there Magus bride
is in my opinion one of the best shows
airing this season that stood out
immediately from episode 1 the first
thing that caught my attention was a
story of an order aristocratic mage
putting down 5 million quid for a 15
year old teenage slave who he then
reveals he'll be grooming as her bone
daddy to be an apprentice and eventual
wife to which I thought all right that's
a bit weird ha ha ha but then again we
live in a fandom where we can casually
call each other a pedo for watching era
manga sensei before going about our day
so it's not something I paid much mind
to as the second thing that God we are a
bit weird aren't we as the second thing
that stuck with me was the beautiful
world which they inhabit filled with
mystique and wonder which is what I'm
here to discuss and not the questionable
Stockholm Syndrome s relationship shared
by a manger which someone else can
unpack oh yeah that's right here's the
water
Elias resides in this magical world of
dragons fairies and phenomenon that
induced that sense of awe and wonder
which comes with living
this enormous place of mysteries
beauties and terrors these shows make a
world so compelling that it's just a joy
to inhabit and explore them from a
third-person perspective viewing it at
least and in this time of the same more
tiresome JRPGs MMO fantasy settings
Clara Yamazaki the original manga Kerr
has managed to craft a world that not
only feels fresh but somewhat familiar
to that we actually want to explore and
learn more of but how does she do that
one of the first things you may notice
is the amazing attention to detail
that's been put into the setting and its
environment and this can be seen right
from episode 1 hold on a sec they're
eating fish and chips with Shep aspire
and aside from this grossly inaccurate
use of American bacon that's actually a
proper full English breakfast are they
about to go to the nearest boonies to
grab a burger and pine and this is the
actual proper sea passage you see on a
British train and you may think it's
stupid that I'm in order they got the
pattern of a [ __ ] train seat right
but it's these small little details that
make this world feel real and unique
because what would stick out like a sore
thumb is having an English setting with
a traditional British cottage and some
chick laying down a piece of onigiri or
some [ __ ]
or even were seeing some madman putting
a teabag in a mug after they poured the
water Jesus the small things can mean a
lot and the same level of attention and
care was given to the fictional part of
the world to see magic and fantasy is
not new to anime in the slightest some
may even say has become kind of a
research rated recently thanks to the
abundance of shows with characters being
all together now transport it to a
fantasy world wait but if you've seen my
video nice ago you should be an expert
on right now and as mentioned there this
new trend has swept over the fantasy
genre in anime causing countless titles
with a grounding JRPG in MMO fantasy
games so much so that we rarely do see
anything new or peculiar that really
surprises us anymore it's like the term
fantasy an anime now means that we are
hard stuck in some medieval theme town
full of your usual NPCs playing that
same chirpy RPG soundtrack loop from
your nightmares with every major
character fitting into one of your usual
basic classes of sword wankum magic
wanker healing wanker priests wanker
bandit wanker and tip wanker
with even the magic itself being
something that we fully understand you
have your typical elemental spells fire
ice and wind or lightning attacks a
summon man
pulls healing spells buffs and debuffs
it's something that's become oddly
familiar either through our
familiarization of the games that have
inspired them or through the sheer
number of titles out now with this
concept which means that no matter how
good the story is or new interesting
spin they put on the characters the
world themselves have gotten stale once
we start getting familiarize with all
the aspects of these worlds and the
systems of magic that govern them what
should be unique features within these
settings for us become something that we
are tyring ly accustomed to in other
words magic ceases to be magical did I
like a complete contrast Magus pride
takes inspiration from all varieties and
mythologies and manages to blend them
into a coherent setting a world with
fairies dragons magical libraries
strange giant rat creatures Cory
Yamazaki is obviously a big fantasy nerd
as she tried she's throwing as many
little references as she can for example
for the term slay begi we can find the
origins of the term as so slay begi
sleigh bells Santa Claus Christmas the
Nativity Jesus Jesus's father Joseph Joe
Joestar Joseph Joestar Joe Joe this is a
[ __ ] Jojo roughly Peggy is
actually a reference to some really
obscure Celtic folklore where sleigh
begi is a type of fairy and when you
meet this character was her name again
tit Tania
titania you know the queen of titty
fairies the queen of fairies she
mentions her wad of tiene nog which is
from Irish mythology a name for the
Otherworld a supernatural realm of
everlasting youth and these are just two
of a manney there someone who's not too
deep into fantasy like myself it would
take a lot of time to research and
unpack but you can tell how much love
and care she has put into this world the
origins of a lot of these myths and
tales are stories that were conjured up
long ago to explain things that people
did not understand at the time and this
is the exact feeling the show gives off
that's right boys my main man Magus
bride is bringing the magic back into
magic there are aspects about the world
that are just delightful which
from the stories held there one that
really sticks to mine was a story of an
old dragon and honestly that's not even
much of a story there we just learned
that when dragons die they turn into
trees and we meet an odd dragon close to
his deathbed with a bunch of kid dragons
innocently cheering him on to pass on so
that he can become a tree and you're
just like well kids don't you just have
the most delightful view of the
acceptance of our own mortality in the
grim inevitability yeah but they're not
leads into this beautiful scene that
encapsulates the true or and beauty in
this world of this magnificent creature
passing on that is just just did I just
cry over a [ __ ] tree all right kids
you all right why don't we all just die
and turn into magnificent trees the
story of this dragon is something very
simple but it was just such a delight to
see this one aspect of the wild it's
comparable to some of the beauty we get
to see from documentaries of our own
earth and this is just one story to be
told within this setting
which brings me to how the show makes it
such a joy to explore the world and it
all boils down to one thing
mystery shopper calm to hammer this
point down I actually think made in the
best has a more straightforward example
I can use the world of maiden abyss
revolves around the exploration of the
abyss which is essentially just a big
hole in the ground that no one knows the
origin of with a bottom that's never
been reached upon seeing this hole you
get the same question that anyone would
get when stumbling on a really deep hole
how deep is the hole what creatures can
I find in it
what made to this hole but most
importantly what happens if I throw a
rock in it it's an innate curiosity
that's hardwired into our psychology
meaning that your natural instinct after
seeing a very very deep hole is to throw
a [ __ ] rock in it's the same instinct
that would cause a stupid kid to poke at
around here and stick his hand in it as
we explore the abyss you start to see
stranger creatures and phenomenon in the
environment some of which we learn about
some of which we don't but it's the
sense of the mystery behind everything
and discovering what they are really
about that makes the setting such an
interesting place to explore Max's
brides world also does exactly that with
its inhabitants and strange phenomenon
what is the story behind this strange
mysterious black goo is their history
behind it and what would happen if I
poked it with a stick and stuck my hand
in it the world is laden with mystery
that we
or through the characters but rather
than uncovering the mystery of a plot
point we are unraveling the puzzle that
is the world itself that they inhabit as
we are learning everything through the
eyes of she say the typical magic new we
start off with the same grounding and
knowledge as she does allowing us to
discover things at the same pace but you
get the sense that even those who have
existed in the world for lifetimes
longer still are nowhere near in
understanding everything it has to offer
details I mentioned that uh never
explains characters have rich history
that are only implied at and rarely they
would get some kind of exposition dump
that explains exactly everything that we
see we are only given the information we
need to be given it doesn't feel like a
world that was created for the purpose
of taking us through an adventure it's
one that simply exists and has existed
for a very long time one that we cannot
fully explore filled with features
nobody may ever really understand like
our actual world and universe we are not
meant to be able to comprehend
everything as the phenomenon are bigger
than any one person and while made in
the best uses this concept to
effectively build a sense of dread
through its Lovecraftian horror Magus
bride uses this to craft a location that
feels like a living breathing place
beyond our understanding which would
just be wonderful to dwell in all this
bills to create the mesmerizing
atmosphere that Magus bride has one that
really encapsulates what fantasy should
be like it feels magical
it feels delightful invoking a sense of
awe and it's not just something that's
exclusive to the anime many of argue
that the manga has done an even better
job at crafting that rich atmosphere
which I should probably mention is on
book Walker links below and details
coming up but from what I have read it's
also impressed me greatly I mentioned
during my first impression that I was
waiting for that hook in the plot but
the more I watched the more I realized I
didn't need a hook in some plot point to
grip me what kept me coming back was
just wanting to see more of the world
because that is the magic of
experiencing a new world and a new world
doesn't necessarily have to mean an
entirely fictional one an alien one or a
fantasy one that is beyond our
imagination it could just mean a world
outside the one you are normally exposed
to this video will probably be watched
by thousands of people around the world
of different backgrounds locations
environments that you may or may not
have some familiar
with and even if we look at our own
world there are still so many mysterious
fantastical and beautiful things that
look like they belong in our imagination
and when we look at these fictional
worlds with such mystique and wonder we
can forget the some of the most
mysterious and wonderful things inhabit
our own world already and while I'm sure
most of us are not travelers or
documentary makers exploring these
delightful strange facets of our world
the true magic of fantasy worlds like
these is how they can make us feel like
we are
[Music]
if the world of magus bride sounds like
something you'd like to explore side
from just the anime you can always read
ahead in the manga which I do highly
recommend which you can do so on book
walker using coupon code Giga for a
discount
no giveaway this time I just wanted to
talk about a great title they are doing
a giveaway for spice more stuff right
now though for the new series that just
came out so if that interests you you
can also enter by buying the new spice
and wolf book again same coupon code
same discount but anyway that's it from
me I've been gigging and I will see you
all next time
hahaha